Let me tell you my favorite thing about waking up in an Airbnb versus a hotel. Okay. I wake up, I do not shower. I don't even have to brush my teeth. I just throw on a robe and I walk to the little kitchen and I pour myself a cup of coffee. The point is I can start my day in private. I don't have to go to a lobby. I don't have to go to a diner next door.
让我来告诉你，比起住酒店，我最喜欢住Airbnb的一点是什么。好吧。我醒来后不用洗澡。甚至连牙都不用刷。我只需要披上一件长袍，走到小厨房，给自己倒杯咖啡。重点是，我可以私密地开始我的一天。我不需要去大堂，也不需要去隔壁的餐馆。
There's no chit chat in the elevator. No. My favorite thing are those slow, lazy, cozy mornings when I'm on vacation. I can take my time. Yeah. I also love it too if you stay somewhere and it has like a hot tub, you know. It's just going to be you and your family. You're not going to be like trying to squeeze in there with a bunch of people.
电梯里没有闲聊。没有。我最喜欢的是度假时那些缓慢、慵懒、舒适的早晨。我可以慢慢来。是的。如果你住的地方有热水浴缸，我也很喜欢，你知道的。那只会是你和你的家人。你不需要像在酒店那样，试图和一群陌生人挤在一起。
Yeah, or any kind of outdoor space is such a treat. Consider Airbnb for your next travel adventure. Did you know that parents rank financial literacy as the number one most difficult life skill to teach? Meet Greenlight, the debit card and money app for families. With Greenlight, you can send money to kids instantly, set up chores, automate allowance, and keep an eye on your kids' spending
是的，或者任何户外空间都是一种享受。考虑一下在你的下一次旅行冒险中选择Airbnb吧。你知道吗？家长们将金融素养列为最难教给孩子的生活技能之首。来认识一下Greenlight，这是一款专为家庭设计的借记卡和理财应用程序。有了Greenlight，你可以即时给孩子汇款、安排家务、自动发放零花钱，并随时关注孩子的消费情况，
with real-time notifications. Kids get to earn, save, and spend wisely, and parents can rest easy knowing their kids are learning about money with guardrails in place. Sign up for Greenlight today at greenlight.com slash odyssey. Greenlight today at greenlight.com slash Odyssey. Hello and welcome to our second drink of Hot Girl. We're doing something a little differently this week. When we revisited our breakdown of Hot Girl,
通过实时通知。孩子们可以学会赚钱、储蓄和明智地消费，而家长们也可以放心，因为他们知道孩子们是在有保障措施的情况下学习理财的。今天就去greenlight.com/odyssey注册Greenlight吧。今天就去greenlight.com/Odyssey注册Greenlight。你好，欢迎来到我们的第二杯《Hot Girl》。这周我们要做点不一样的。当我们重新回顾对《Hot Girl》的解析时，
we noticed that there were quite a few things that we missed, that we could have talked about. And we kind of wanted to break it down again. Yes, because so many of you have also written to us and asked us if we would break down some of the Peacock superfan episodes. So we thought, why not do a full breakdown of the superfan episode of Hot Girl?
我们注意到还有很多东西我们漏掉了，本可以讨论的。我们想再次进行解析。是的，因为你们中也有很多人写信给我们，问我们是否会解析一些Peacock的超级粉丝剧集。所以我们想，为什么不做一个《Hot Girl》超级粉丝剧集的完整解析呢？
So this Wednesday, we're going to do it. We're going to be breaking down the superfan episode of Hot Girl. And if you don't have Peacock, don't worry. We'll fill you in. There is still a lot to enjoy. For example, I got to do my Dunder Mifflin hallway investigation. You're very excited about it.
所以这个周三，我们要这么做。我们将解析《Hot Girl》的超级粉丝剧集。如果你没有Peacock，别担心。我们会告诉你内容的。仍然有很多值得欣赏的地方。例如，我终于做了我的邓德·米夫林走廊调查。你对此非常兴奋。
Well, Dave Rogers told us there's a deleted scene from Hot Girl that really sheds some light on where all these hallways go. I can't wait. I also really want to talk about this extended scene between Michael and Ryan where they're talking about music. It's so funny. It's hilarious. All right, please enjoy this second drink of Hot Girl, and we will see you Wednesday.
嗯，戴夫·罗杰斯告诉我们，《Hot Girl》里有一个删减片段，真的揭示了这些走廊通向哪里。我等不及了。我还真的很想谈谈迈克尔和瑞恩之间那段关于音乐的加长片段。太搞笑了。简直滑稽。好了，请享受这第二杯《Hot Girl》，我们周三见。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。
We're The Office ladies. That's us. Hey there. We are here. We are here and we're excited because today we're talking about Hot Girl. Hot Girl Season 1 Episode 6 written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Amy Heckerling. I was really excited to meet Amy Heckerling, growing up, guys, I might be a child of the 70s.
我们是《办公室》女士。那就是我们。嘿，大家好。我们在这儿。我们在这儿，我们很兴奋，因为今天我们要谈论《Hot Girl》。《Hot Girl》，第一季第六集，由敏迪·卡灵编剧，艾米·海克林执导。我真的很兴奋能见到艾米·海克林，伙计们，我可能是个70后的孩子。
No judgment, the oldie sitting here. No, and she directed Fast Times at Ridgemont High and Clueless. Clueless. Clueless, so I was excited. I remember there was a bit of a buzz. Yeah, there was a little bit of a buzz. That she was coming in. We were very excited. I didn't know how to make a buzz. Yeah, there was a little bit of a buzz. That she was coming in.
别评判，老人家坐在这儿呢。不，她执导了《开放的美国学府》和《独领风骚》。《独领风骚》。《独领风骚》，所以我很兴奋。我记得当时有一点轰动。是的，确实有一点轰动。她要来了。我们非常兴奋。我不知道该怎么制造轰动。是的，确实有一点轰动。她要来了。
Yeah. We were very excited. I didn't know how to make small talk with her and guess what? I failed. All right, Jenna, hit us with a synopsis. All right, synopsis of this episode. Michael allows a woman selling purses to set up in the conference room for the day and Michael and Dwight compete for her attention.
是的。我们非常兴奋。我不知道该怎么和她寒暄，结果呢？我失败了。好了，珍娜，给我们来个剧情简介。好的，这一集的剧情简介。迈克尔允许一位卖手提包的女士在会议室待上一天，迈克尔和德怀特为了吸引她的注意而展开竞争。
Very simple. Very simple. And yet. So loaded for Pam. This was really a big Pam episode. It really was. So should we start with some fast facts then? I know you want to. You know.
非常简单。非常简单。但却。对帕姆来说内容太丰富了。这真的是帕姆的一大集。确实是。那我们先从一些快讯开始吧？我知道你想。你知道的。
My fast fact, number one, this is the first episode written by Mindy Kaling. Yes, Mindy Kaling's so smart, so funny. And she was one of our most prolific writers on The Office. She wrote a total of, Jenna, ready? What? 22 episodes. Wow.
我的第一条快讯，这是敏迪·卡灵编剧的第一集。是的，敏迪·卡灵太聪明了，太搞笑了。她是我们在《办公室》中最具多产的编剧之一。她总共写了，珍娜，准备好了吗？什么？22集。哇。
I know. That's like she wrote an entire season of The Office. I know, I know. Of our night, cause the season's usually about 22, 24 episodes. I have a fan question about Mindy. All right. This is from Bear.
我知道。就像她写了《办公室》整整一季。我知道，我知道。我们的一季通常大约是22到24集。我有一个关于敏迪的粉丝问题。好的。这是来自贝尔的。
Hi, Bear. Yes, Bear asked, this episode was written by Mindy Kaling. What was it like to work with her as a writer versus an actor? Oh, Bear, good question. I know. You know what? I loved when Mindy was the writer of the episode,
嗨，贝尔。是的，贝尔问，这一集是由敏迪·卡灵编剧的。作为编剧和作为演员与她共事有什么不同？哦，贝尔，好问题。我知道。你知道吗？我喜欢敏迪担任编剧的时候，
because the writer of the episode on our show would stay on set all week and produce their episode with the director. So they kind of worked very side by side with the director. Yes, and they were sort of the liaison back to the writer's room. I love that our show did this. Not all shows do that. And I really think you benefit from having the writer of the episode on the set with you.
因为我们剧集的编剧会整周待在片场，和导演一起制作他们的剧集。所以他们和导演的工作非常紧密。是的，他们算是回到编剧室的联络人。我喜欢我们的剧集这样做。并非所有剧集都这样做。我真的认为让剧集编剧在片场陪着你，你会受益匪浅。
Well, Mindy, it was so easy to make Mindy laugh. Like she was so ready to love everything you were doing. You were filled with such confidence when Mindy was on the set. And she also was really good on the spot coming up with new jokes, because that was another thing that the writer of the episode would do. They would pitch you improvisations on the spot. Yeah, and Mindy, for me, as someone with an improv background, I loved
嗯，敏迪，让敏迪笑太容易了。她总是准备好喜欢你所做的一切。当敏迪在片场时，你充满了自信。而且她也非常擅长即兴创作新笑话，因为这也是剧集编剧会做的事情。他们会当场向你推销即兴表演。是的，敏迪，对我来说，作为一个有即兴表演背景的人，我喜欢
being able to pitch to Mindy because she's so smart. So I could say, hey, Mindy, could I try this? And then she would just instantly be like, oh, that'd be great. Or how about you do this? She was such a wonderful, creative collaborator. I always felt like Mindy was such a big advocate for the character of Pam as well.
能够向敏迪推销，因为她太聪明了。所以我可以说，嘿，敏迪，我能试试这个吗？然后她会立刻说，哦，那太棒了。或者你试试这样做怎么样？她是一位非常出色的创意合作伙伴。我一直觉得敏迪也是帕姆这个角色的坚定支持者。
I think she was in the writer's room pitching storylines for Pam, and this was a very Pam-centered episode, as we said. Pam has feelings. She has a lot of feelings. Pam has a lot of feelings. She does. This leads me into my second fastback. I was texting with Mindy about this episode in preparation, and she told me something.
我想她在编剧室里为帕姆推销故事情节，正如我们所说，这是一集以帕姆为中心的剧集。帕姆有感情。她有很多感情。帕姆有很多感情。她确实有。这引出了我的第二个快讯。在准备过程中，我正和敏迪发短信讨论这一集，她告诉了我一件事。
What? The original title of this episode was Purse Girl. Do you kind of remember that? I actually do, because I feel like I have referred to this as Purse Girl a few times, because it's in my brain. Yeah. She also told me that her original draft of this
什么？这一集的原始标题是《手提包女孩》。你还记得吗？我确实记得，因为我觉得我曾几次把它称为《手提包女孩》，因为它在我的脑海里。是的。她还告诉我，她的原始草稿
was 39 pages. Yeah. She also told me that her original draft of this was 39 pages. Wow. Which is a lot, because usually the number of pages that a script is, that's how many minutes of screen time it is. So her script, if we did it exactly as written, would have been 39 minutes, which we would not have been able to air.
有39页。是的。她还告诉我，她的原始草稿有39页。哇。这很多，因为通常剧本的页数就是屏幕时间的分钟数。所以她的剧本，如果我们完全按照书面内容拍摄，会有39分钟，那是我们无法播出的。
I really wish we could have done that. And I wish we could have filmed all 40 pages of that instead of 22, 22 minutes. I remember they used to have done that. And I wish we could have filmed all 40 pages of that instead of 22, 22 minutes. I remember they used to have those very long table drafts and then they would cut a bunch of stuff out and they would make something they called the candy bag. And those were all of the cut scenes or they were additional takes on scenes.
我真希望我们能做到。我真希望我们能拍摄那全部40页，而不是22分钟。我记得他们过去常那样做。我真希望我们能拍摄那全部40页，而不是22分钟。我记得他们过去常有那些非常长的台本草稿，然后他们会删掉很多东西，制作出他们称之为“糖果袋”的东西。那些都是被删减的场景，或者是场景的额外拍摄。
So whatever talking head wound up in the script, there would be five different takes on that talking head in the candy bag. And so we would sit down to do our talking heads and they would say, all right, well, we're going to do the scripted one, but then we're going to do three of them from the candy bag. Oh, I remember going to do a talking head and they handed me three pages of alts, like right in the minute. I'm like, oh, right. Okay. I'm going to have to have a photographic memory.
所以无论剧本里最终出现了什么采访镜头，在“糖果袋”里都会有五种不同的拍摄版本。所以当我们坐下来拍摄采访镜头时，他们会说，好吧，我们要拍剧本里的那个，但之后我们要拍三个来自“糖果袋”的。哦，我记得有一次去拍采访镜头，他们给了我三页的替代台词，就在那一分钟。我心想，哦，好吧。我得有照相记忆力才行。
You have to really be on your toes. I think that's something that It kept us on our toes for sure. I loved it. I loved it too. And then they used to let me play around and like sort of like put my spin on it too, which was always fun. All right, Fisher, what else you got?
你真的必须时刻保持警惕。我认为这是……它确实让我们保持了警惕。我喜欢它。我也喜欢。而且他们过去常让我随意发挥，把我的个人风格加进去，这总是很有趣。好了，费舍尔，你还有什么？
All right, I think it's time to talk about Amy Adams. Okay, I have a lot of note cards here in front of me. I see, and a lot of them have the words Amy or Amy Adams on them. You tell me when you're ready because I've got a noteecard ready to go. Well, this is our third fast fact. Okay.
好的，我觉得是时候谈谈艾米·亚当斯了。好的，我面前有很多笔记卡。我看到了，而且很多上面都写着艾米或艾米·亚当斯。你准备好了就告诉我，因为我已经准备好了一张笔记卡。嗯，这是我们的第三条快讯。好的。
Amy Adams was the Purse Girl. Mindy told me that Amy was her favorite from the very beginning. This is who she wanted to cast as the Purse Girl from her audition. But something that I think people don't realize is that Amy Adams wasn't Amy Adams when she was cast as the Purse Girl. She became Amy Adams wasn't Amy Adams when she was cast as the Purse Girl. She became Amy Adams later. And that's an interesting story actually because we filmed this episode in the fall of 2004,
艾米·亚当斯就是那个“手提包女孩”。敏迪告诉我，艾米从一开始就是她的最爱。这就是她从试镜中想要选为“手提包女孩”的人。但我觉得人们没有意识到的一点是，艾米·亚当斯在被选为“手提包女孩”时还不是艾米·亚当斯。她后来才成为了艾米·亚当斯。这是一个有趣的故事，因为我们是在2004年秋天拍摄这一集的，
but they didn't start airing until the spring of 2005. And that fall, she was nominated for an Academy Award for her role in June Bug. Right, when she did this episode of The Office, no one had seen Junebug yet, because Junebug came out in August of 2005. Yes. And I remember her first day on set,
但直到2005年春天它们才开始播出。那个秋天，她凭借在《甲壳虫》中的角色获得了奥斯卡提名。没错，当她拍摄这一集《办公室》时，还没有人看过《甲壳虫》，因为《甲壳虫》是在2005年8月上映的。是的。我记得她第一天到片场，
we were talking and I was like, how are things going? She was like, well, you know, it's good. I mean, I was on a show on CBS called Dr. Vegas, but they like, they let me go. Oh, that's right. She was like, I kinda got fired. And I was like, no. And she was like, yeah.
我们在聊天，我问，情况怎么样？她说，嗯，你知道，还不错。我的意思是，我曾在CBS的一部叫《拉斯维加斯医生》的剧里，但他们让我走了。哦，那是真的。她说，我有点被解雇了。我说，不。她说，是的。
And I was really down and I was bummed out. But then, you know, I did of got fired. And I was like, no. And she was like, yeah. And I was really down. And I was bummed out. But then I did this little indie movie called June Bug. And I feel so good about it. And it's going to come out later in the year. And I was like, oh, that sounds great. Yeah. Let me build you up, Amy Adams.
我当时真的很沮丧，很失落。但后来，你知道，我被解雇了。我说，不。她说，是的。我当时真的很沮丧。我很难过。但后来我拍了一部叫《甲壳虫》的小型独立电影。我感觉很好。它会在今年晚些时候上映。我说，哦，那听起来太棒了。是的。让我为你加油，艾米·亚当斯。
Amy, you're going to be just fine. And she was. And she was. But Amy is one of the nicest people. She's so, so sweet. Oh, I loved Amy. It was so fun working with her. There were a lot of questions from fans asking if we planned to bring this character back
艾米，你会没事的。她确实没事。她确实没事。但艾米是最好的人之一。她非常非常甜美。哦，我爱艾米。和她一起工作太有趣了。有很多粉丝问我们是否计划在拍摄结束后让这个角色回归。
after we shot it. Well, we didn't think we were going to have a show. There were no real plans to bring her back. But then when the show got picked up, they wanted to bring her back. But now she was Academy Award nominated Amy Adams. So I was like, well, I hope we can get her back. And we did, she came back for two more episodes. Yes, and she was such a great foil too
嗯，我们当时没想过我们会有剧集。没有真正的计划让她回归。但当剧集被续订后，他们想让她回来。但现在她是获得奥斯卡提名的艾米·亚当斯了。所以我当时想，嗯，我希望我们能请回她。我们做到了，她又回来拍了两集。是的，她也是一个很棒的陪衬，
for Pam and Jim and all of that. I loved watching that play out. Not only was Amy Adams super nice on set and just like such a pleasure to work with, but I don't know, probably like two years later, I ran into her. I had a friend visiting from Alabama and you guys, I don't ever go out. So my friend was coming in town and I was like, oh, I'm going to take her somewhere fancy.
对于帕姆和吉姆以及所有这些。我喜欢看那一切上演。艾米·亚当斯不仅在片场超级好，而且和她一起工作真是一种乐趣，而且我不知道，大概两年后，我遇到了她。我有一个朋友从阿拉巴马州来看我，伙计们，我从不出门。所以我朋友要来城里，我说，哦，我要带她去个高档的地方。
That hotel Chateau Marmont, that's fancy. We'll go there. Because I just had it in my head. Yeah, like the Hollywood fancy place to eat. It was a fancy place. Yeah. I mean, it's like half an hour from my house. It was such a like hall. But I was like, no, I to eat. It was a fancy place. I mean, it's like half an hour from my house. It was such a hall.
那个Chateau Marmont酒店，那很高级。我们去那儿吧。因为我脑子里就是这么想的。是的，就像好莱坞的高级用餐场所。那是个高级地方。是的。我的意思是，离我家半小时路程。那真是一个……用餐场所。那是个高级地方。我的意思是，离我家半小时路程。那真是一个……
But I was like, no, I'll take my friend from Alabama there. So we went, and we were having dinner. And Amy Adams was at a table, and she sent over two glasses of champagne to my friend and I. And I was like, turn. They were like, oh, this is champagne. Classy move, Amy Adams. And I was like, who's this from?
但我说，不，我要带我阿拉巴马州的朋友去那儿。所以我们去了，我们正在吃晚饭。艾米·亚当斯也在一张桌子旁，她给我们送来了两杯香槟。我说，转过来。他们说，哦，这是香槟。高级的举动，艾米·亚当斯。我说，这是谁送的？
They were like, it's from Amy Adams. And she waved, and then she came over, and we chatted. Amy Adams is just a class act. I have a funny Amy Adams story about how people think that we look alike. So she and I were both at this work party thing. I can't remember exactly. I think it was like honoring directors in the industry.
他们说，是艾米·亚当斯送的。她挥了挥手，然后她走过来，我们聊了聊。艾米·亚当斯真是个有格调的人。我有一个关于艾米·亚当斯的有趣故事，关于人们认为我们长得很像。所以她和我都在那个工作派对上。我不记得确切了。我想那是在表彰行业内的导演。
And we were both there. And my friend came up to me, and he said, I am so humiliated right now. And I said, what happened? And he goes, I just went up and bear hugged Amy Adams and said, Jenna, you look beautiful. Oh, no, because he mixed us up. And this people have this thing where they think she and I look a lot alike. We really don't look anything alike in person. Although I guess I just told a story about someone who mixed us up in person. I mean, there is a resemblance. It's she's perfectly cast because there is a resemblance and you're
我们都在那儿。我朋友走过来对我说，我现在太丢脸了。我说，发生了什么？他说，我刚才走过去给了艾米·亚当斯一个熊抱，说，珍娜，你看起来真漂亮。哦，不，因为他把我们搞混了。人们有一种想法，认为她和我长得很像。我们本人其实一点也不像。虽然我想我刚才讲了一个有人把我们本人搞混的故事。我的意思是，确实有相似之处。她选角选得太完美了，因为确实有相似之处，而且你们
both like beautiful ladies. Thanks. But I see a resemblance. I feel like we could play sisters. You could. All right, Hollywood. You heard it here first. That's how I guess that's how I talk when I'm talking to Hollywood. I guess Hollywood beware. Hollywood, this is Angela Kinsey. I don't love it. I would rethink your character, your Hollywood voice lady. I think you should work on it. Okay, thanks.
都是美丽的女士。谢谢。但我看到了相似之处。我觉得我们可以演姐妹。你们可以。好了，好莱坞。你们先听到的。我想这就是我跟好莱坞说话的方式。我想好莱坞要小心了。好莱坞，这是安吉拉·金赛。我不喜欢。我会重新考虑你的角色，你的好莱坞声音女士。我觉得你应该练练。好的，谢谢。
Give it an accent. Should it be British? Hollywood, no, oh my God. That's Australian. Oh, what was that? That was like drunk Scottish. What is happening? I can't do accents and I also can't sing.
给它加个口音。应该是英国口音吗？好莱坞，不，哦天哪。那是澳大利亚口音。哦，那是什么？那听起来像喝醉的苏格兰人。发生了什么？我不会模仿口音，我也不会唱歌。
I can do Australian, but I grew up overseas and all my best friends were Aussies. So right now I'm just sitting here talking to Jenna. We're going to talk about hot girl. Yeah. That's really good, Ange. Oh, thanks. Thanks so much. I'm shocked.
我会模仿澳大利亚口音，但我是在海外长大的，我最好的朋友都是澳大利亚人。所以现在我只是坐在这里和珍娜说话。我们要谈谈《Hot Girl》。是的。那真的很棒，安吉。哦，谢谢。太感谢了。我很震惊。
I'm genuinely impressed. Okay. Okay. Okay. See, that was so good, but your Hollywood voice is a no. I know. You know what? It's whenever I'm trying to be slick. I am just not programmed to be slick.
我真的印象深刻。好的。好的。好的。看，那太棒了，但你的好莱坞声音不行。我知道。你知道吗？每当我试图圆滑的时候。我就是没被设定成圆滑的样子。
This is true about you. Before we go to a break, since we're talking about Amy Adams and how wonderful she is both on and off set, we have to tell the story about how she helped us meet Meryl Streep. Oh my god, oh my god. I cannot believe I didn't put that on a notecard. I can't believe it either. What is wrong with me? I don't know. I got here, there were donuts, I got excited, I forgot. Okay. So one year, we got to go to the Golden Globes. Oh. The office had been nominated. And I have to say, first of all, Angela, I am so grateful that I got to go
关于你这一点是真的。在我们休息之前，既然我们在谈论艾米·亚当斯以及她在片场内外是多么棒，我们必须讲讲她是如何帮助我们见到梅丽尔·斯特里普的故事。哦天哪，哦天哪。我不敢相信我没把它写在笔记卡上。我也不敢相信。我怎么了？我不知道。我到了那儿，有甜甜圈，我很兴奋，我忘了。好的。所以有一年，我们去了金球奖。哦。《办公室》被提名了。我必须说，首先，安吉拉，我非常感激我能和你一起去
to these award show things with you. I know, well, here's the thing, we didn't go to fancy parties, you guys, we're not fancy people. I'm intimate dinner party person. Well, I- I like a small group. I think the fanciest parties I'd ever been to
这些颁奖典礼。我知道，嗯，事情是这样的，我们没去参加高级派对，伙计们，我们不是高级人士。我是亲密晚宴的人。嗯，我……我喜欢小团体。我想我去过的最高级的派对
were just like when one of my friends would have a big wedding. But I am so glad that I got to navigate all that stuff with you because I would normally kind of freeze up at something like that, but I was there with my BFF. We would have a couple glasses of wine. We would sometimes get a little,
只是像我朋友举行盛大婚礼的时候。但我很高兴我能和你一起处理所有这些事情，因为我通常在那种场合会僵住，但我当时和我的闺蜜在一起。我们会喝几杯酒。我们有时会有点……
well, because one thing we should say is we were not allowed to bring a plus one. Well, we were not big time enough. No. I feel like we were barely invited. Truth be told. Even though our show was nominated, it did feel like that. Well, first of all, wait, wait, wait, do you remember where our table was? Very far away from our table was behind a pillar, Jenna. I had to sort of lean all the way like towards Brian's lap to see the stage. Yeah, so the Golden Globes are really cool
嗯，因为有一件事我们应该说，我们不允许带加一。嗯，我们还不够大牌。不。我觉得我们几乎没被邀请。说实话。尽管我们的剧集被提名了，但感觉确实如此。嗯，首先，等等，等等，你还记得我们的桌子在哪儿吗？离我们的桌子很远，在柱子后面，珍娜。我不得不一直向布莱恩的膝盖那边倾斜才能看到舞台。是的，所以金球奖真的很酷，
because they have awards for both movies and television. So as- There are cool movie stars you see. Yeah, as TV people, we were in the room with Angelina Jolie suddenly and Brad Pitt and all those people. We were nowhere near them though. They were down at the front and we were in the nosebleeds,
因为他们有电影和电视的奖项。所以作为……你会看到很酷的电影明星。是的，作为电视人，我们突然和安吉丽娜·朱莉、布拉德·皮特以及所有那些人待在同一个房间里。不过我们离他们很远。他们在前排，我们在高处，
but hey, we were in the room. Well, I will say, I remember going to the bathroom and Angelina Jolie passed by. She took my breath away. I thought, well, now she is from the gods. I get that. I mean, that is a movie star. Well, you turned to me because we were like in line
但嘿，我们在那个房间里。嗯，我会说，我记得去洗手间时安吉丽娜·朱莉经过。她让我屏住了呼吸。我想，好吧，她真是天神下凡。我懂那个。我的意思是，那才是电影明星。嗯，你转向我，因为我们当时在排队
for the bathroom and she just sort of, it's like she glided. It's like she floated past us. And you turned to me and you go, now that's a movie star. I did. I saw like an old lady. Now that is a movie star. I was like, I don't disagree, Jenna.
上洗手间，她就那样，就像滑行一样。就像她从我们身边飘过。你转向我，说，那才是电影明星。我说了。我看到了像个老太太。那才是电影明星。我说，我不反对，珍娜。
So Jenna and I are not two people that are invited to a lot of fancy parties. And also, if there are going to be two dorks at a party, chances are they're us. Oh yeah. That's just us anywhere. We've done some real dorky things at parties. We are just kind of dorks, even if it's just like at our neighbor's barbecue. I was glad I got to go to those parties with you because I knew you felt as awkward at them as I did.
所以珍娜和我不是那种被邀请参加很多高级派对的人。而且，如果派对上有两个书呆子，那很可能就是我们。哦，是的。无论在哪儿都是我们。我们在派对上做过一些真正书呆子的事情。我们就是那种书呆子，即使只是在我们邻居的烧烤会上。我很高兴能和你一起去那些派对，因为我知道你和我在那里一样感到尴尬。
But you are way braver than I am. Way braver. That is true. I have a little bit of my mom's voice in my ear, and my mom would say, if you are at a fancy party, you need to meet the fancy people. You need to use it as an opportunity. Come on, go say hi to the people you want to say hi to. So I always had that in the back of my head.
但你比我勇敢得多。勇敢得多。那是真的。我耳边总有我妈妈的声音，我妈妈会说，如果你在高级派对上，你需要去见高级人士。你需要把它当作一个机会。来吧，去和你想要打招呼的人打个招呼。所以我脑子里总是有那个想法。
This is my only chance to whatever. Hobnob? Yeah, meet whoever I've always wanted to meet, I guess. But how do you get? How do you get into the conversation is always the mystery. So at this Golden Globe, we had our in, we look across the room and we see Amy Adams talking to Meryl Streep. We lean around the pillar, we're sitting behind and we see Amy Adams. You should know at this point we'd been sitting at our table for quite a while.
这是我唯一的机会去……结交权贵？是的，去见任何我一直想见的人，我想。但你怎么进入？你怎么进入谈话总是谜。所以在这次金球奖上，我们有了切入点，我们看向房间对面，看到艾米·亚当斯在和梅丽尔·斯特里普交谈。我们绕过我们坐的柱子，看到艾米·亚当斯。你应该知道，此时我们已经在桌子旁坐了很久了。
We hadn't got up and mingled other than we went to the bathroom and saw Angelina Jolie walk by and we didn't say a word. No, I did not speak to her. We did not speak to her. So Jenna's like, there's Amy Adams and Angela, she's talking to Meryl Streep. We know Amy Adams. Yes.
我们除了去洗手间看到安吉丽娜·朱莉走过之外，没有起身交际，而且我们一句话也没说。不，我没跟她说话。我们没跟她说话。所以珍娜说，那是艾米·亚当斯，安吉拉，她在和梅丽尔·斯特里普说话。我们认识艾米·亚当斯。是的。
We can go talk to Amy Adams. We know her. She likes us. Yes. And then maybe we'll get to meet some movie stars. Yeah, we'll just basically glom on to Amy Adams was our plan. Yeah, and Jenna was like, come on, Angela, let's go. And I was like, nope, don't want to go. Not going, not going. And you really like you were like,
我们可以去和艾米·亚当斯说话。我们认识她。她喜欢我们。是的。然后也许我们就能见到一些电影明星了。是的，我们基本上会粘上艾米·亚当斯，这是我们的计划。是的，珍娜说，来吧，安吉拉，我们走。我说，不，不想去。不去，不去。你真的……你就像是，
Angela? I pulled you from the table. I said, we are meeting Meryl Streep. We are doing this. This is a story for my mother. Come on. And then she said, and you got to be quick. You have to be quick because what if they what if Amy stops talking to her? Yeah, let's go And then she said, and you gotta be quick. You have to be quick, because what if Amy stops talking to her? Yeah, let's go. And you said, well, what are we gonna do? What are we gonna say? How do you walk up to them? What are we gonna say?
安吉拉？我把你从桌子旁拉走了。我说，我们要去见梅丽尔·斯特里普。我们要这么做。这是给我妈妈讲的故事。来吧。然后她说，你得快点。你必须快点，因为如果艾米停止和她说话怎么办？是的，走吧。然后她说，你得快点。你必须快点，因为如果艾米停止和她说话怎么办？是的，走吧。你说，好吧，我们要干什么？我们要说什么？你怎么走过去？我们要说什么？
So I was like, here's my plan. We are just gonna walk up to them laughing. What? Just laugh. What? And I said, laugh at what? It doesn't matter. What are we laughing at?
所以我说，这是我的计划。我们走过去的时候要笑着。什么？就笑。什么？我说，笑什么？没关系。我们在笑什么？
I said, it doesn't matter. Just walk up to them laughing. Jenna, I think you thought if we just walked up laughing, we would look? What are we laughing at? It doesn't matter. I said, it doesn't matter. Just walk up to them laughing. I think you thought if we just walked up laughing, we would look cool. Like we're like. I don't know what I thought, Angela. I don't know. I just knew we had to seize the moment.
我说，没关系。走过去的时候笑着就行。珍娜，我想你以为如果我们走过去的时候笑着，我们会看起来？我们在笑什么？没关系。我说，没关系。走过去的时候笑着就行。我想你以为如果我们走过去的时候笑着，我们会看起来很酷。就像我们……我不知道我在想什么，安吉拉。我不知道。我只知道我们必须抓住那一刻。
So we did. Well, I said, I basically was like in shock. I was like, wait, what? And then I looked and Jenna was like four strides away. Like kind of like. I committed and Jenna was like four strides away, like kind of like- I committed. You're like, come on. And then I sort of half-ass committed behind you.
所以我们做了。嗯，我说，我基本上处于震惊状态。我说，等等，什么？然后我看了看，珍娜已经走了四步远了。就像那种……我投入了，珍娜已经走了四步远了，就像那种……我投入了。你就像，来吧。然后我跟在你后面半心半意地投入了。
And we did just that. We walked up to Meryl Streep and Amy Adams, laughing. And right at that moment, a house photographer came by and snapped our photo. So we have a photo of us and it looks like we are having a hilarious conversation with Meryl Streep and Amy Adams. Well, actually to clarify, it looks like you
我们确实就这样做了。我们笑着走向梅丽尔·斯特里普和艾米·亚当斯。就在那一刻，一位现场摄影师走过来拍下了我们的照片。所以我们有一张照片，看起来我们正在和梅丽尔·斯特里普和艾米·亚当斯进行一场有趣的谈话。嗯，实际上澄清一下，看起来是你
and Amy and Meryl Streep are having a great conversation. But because I lagged behind you a little, I was late getting there and I just look like I'm walking alone laughing. I'm like a good three paces behind you laughing to no one. And you're laughing with Meryl and Amy. But when the lights like flickered cause it was the commercial and we didn't even get to talk to them. I did get to say to Meryl Streep,
和艾米以及梅丽尔·斯特里普在进行一场很棒的谈话。但因为我落后你一点，我到得晚，我看起来就像是一个人走着在笑。我落后你大概三步，对着空气笑。而你在和梅丽尔、艾米笑。但当灯光闪烁时，因为那是广告时间，我们甚至没能和她们说话。我确实对梅丽尔·斯特里普说了，
I did get to say, it's such a pleasure to meet you. I'm a big admirer of your work. And I was, I mean, I just loved her performance in Kramer versus Kramer. I studied a lot of her work. And so as like a theater geek, actory person, we've talked a lot about my love of actor prep. That was a big moment for me.
我确实说了，见到你真是荣幸。我非常钦佩你的作品。我当时，我的意思是，我只是喜欢她在《克莱默夫妇》中的表演。我研究了很多她的作品。所以作为一个戏剧极客，演员类型的人，我们谈了很多关于我对演员准备工作的热爱。那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。
Well, I'm glad you had that moment. I did not meet her. Wait, you didn't meet her? No, I didn't meet her because they were dimming the lights. And so by the time I got there, I was just like, bye. Well, she's one of my best friends now. Oh, you, you. From that moment. Now I've never spoken to her again.
嗯，我很高兴你有那个时刻。我没见到她。等等，你没见到她？不，我没见到她，因为他们正在调暗灯光。所以当我到那儿时，我只是说，再见。嗯，她现在是我最好的朋友之一了。哦，你，你。从那一刻起。现在我再也没和她说过话了。
You've never spoken to her again. My guess is that Meryl Streep doesn't quite remember that moment the way we do. I know. Well, we have a photo of it. We do have a photo. Forever. All right, guys, we're gonna go to a break. And when we come back, we're gonna break down the Hot Girl episode. -♪
你再也没和她说过话了。我猜梅丽尔·斯特里普并不像我们那样记得那一刻。我知道。嗯，我们有照片。我们确实有照片。永远。好了，伙计们，我们要去休息一下。当我们回来时，我们要解析《Hot Girl》这一集。-♪
70,000 people are here, and Bob Dylan is the reason for it. Inspired by the true story... If anyone is gonna hold your attention on stage, you have to kind of be a freak. Are you a freak? Hope so. ...and starring Timothy Chalamet as Bob Dylan...
7万人在这里，鲍勃·迪伦是原因。灵感来自真实故事……如果有人要在舞台上吸引你的注意力，你必须有点怪异。你是怪异的人吗？希望如此。……由蒂莫西·柴勒梅德饰演鲍勃·迪伦……
-♪ How does it feel? -♪ He defied everyone... Turn it down! Play loud! Are you a freak? Hope so. And starring Timothee Chalamet as Bob Dylan, He defied everyone. Turn it down! They loud! To change everything. Make some noise, BD. Timothee Chalamet, Edward Norton, L. Fanny, Monica Barberow, A Complete Unknown. Only theaters Christmas Day.
-♪ 感觉如何？ -♪ 他反抗了所有人……把它关小点！大声点！你是怪异的人吗？希望如此。由蒂莫西·柴勒梅德饰演鲍勃·迪伦，他反抗了所有人。把它关小点！大声点！去改变一切。制造点噪音，BD。蒂莫西·柴勒梅德、爱德华·诺顿、艾丽·范宁、莫妮卡·巴博罗，《完全未知》。圣诞节仅在影院上映。
McDonald's has the gift that keeps giving. To Peter, your dog sitter, and Claire, who shovels your stairs. And to you, when you spend $25 on McDonald's gift cards in restaurants, get a coupon for a free Big Mac or McChicken. See details at participating McDonald's restaurants. This episode is brought to you by Dyson On Track. Dyson On Track headphones offer best-in-class noise cancellation and an enhanced sound range,
麦当劳有不断给予的礼物。给彼得，你的遛狗员，还有克莱尔，帮你铲楼梯雪的人。还有给你，当你在餐厅消费25美元的麦当劳礼品卡时，获得一张免费巨无霸或麦香鸡的优惠券。详情请见参与活动的麦当劳餐厅。本集由Dyson On Track赞助。Dyson On Track耳机提供同类最佳的降噪功能和增强的声音范围，
making them perfect for enjoying music and podcasts. Get up to 55 hours of listening with active noise cancelling enabled, soft microfiber cushions engineered for comfort, and a range of colors and finishes. Dyson On Track. Headphones remastered. Buy from DysonCanada.ca. With ANC on, performance may vary based on environmental conditions and usage. Accessories sold separately.
使其成为享受音乐和播客的完美选择。开启主动降噪功能可享受长达55小时的聆听时间，柔软的超细纤维耳垫专为舒适而设计，并有多种颜色和饰面。Dyson On Track。耳机重制。从DysonCanada.ca购买。开启ANC后，性能可能会根据环境条件和使用情况而有所不同。配件另售。
All right, this episode starts with Michael on a phone call with Jan. She's explaining that they're going to introduce a new incentive program, and the top seller in the office is going to get a prize worth $1,000, and that Michael can choose what that prize is. The end. So, I love that this episode starts with the line, are you listening to me, Michael? By Jan, because he's just like futzing around with pencils
好的，这一集以迈克尔和简的电话开始。她解释说他们要引入一个新的激励计划，办公室里的销售冠军将获得价值1000美元的奖品，迈克尔可以选择奖品是什么。结束。所以，我喜欢这一集以简说的“你在听我说话吗，迈克尔？”开始，因为他只是在摆弄铅笔，
and he has her on speakerphone. But I love that the first scene, you just think he's being an idiot and then you hear this voice say, are you listening to me, Michael? And I just love it. I love it. The next scene when Dwight is standing over Michael's shoulder in the talking head, it begins as a talking head and then it reveals that Dwight has been kind of like hovering.
而且他开了免提。但我喜欢第一个场景，你以为他是个白痴，然后你听到这个声音说，“你在听我说话吗，迈克尔？”我太喜欢了。我喜欢它。下一个场景，当德怀特在采访镜头中站在迈克尔身后时，它以采访镜头开始，然后揭示了德怀特一直在徘徊。
That's the first time we did that. But then we will do that many times in the show. It's one of my favorite things is how Dwight stands over Michael's shoulder. That's also when Pam comes into the office to say someone wants to sell handbags and Michael is totally against it, of course, until he sees how attractive the woman is. A lot of people wrote in and wanted to know where did these purses come from that she's selling. So I called Phil Shea. Our prop master.
那是我们第一次那样做。但后来我们在剧中多次这样做。德怀特站在迈克尔身后是我最喜欢的事情之一。这也是帕姆走进办公室说有人想卖手提包的时候，迈克尔当然完全反对，直到他看到那个女人有多迷人。很多人写信想知道她卖的这些包是从哪儿来的。所以我打电话给菲尔·谢。我们的道具师。
Yes. He told me that he bought them all in downtown LA. Oh, at like the markets downtown? Yes. Oh, the knockoff purse market? Yes. Because some of them looked really nice, but also they looked a little like pleather. I don't think anyone kept them. I didn't keep one. Did you? I didn't know we could. I probably would have taken one. It was early on when we weren't brave enough to ask to take things yet. Yeah, no. Later when the show wrapped, I did take Pam's everyday purse. It's just something that had been sitting, even if I didn't use it in a scene, it sat
是的。他告诉我他是在洛杉矶市中心买的。哦，在市中心的市场？是的。哦，那个仿冒包市场？是的。因为有些看起来确实不错，但也看起来有点像人造革。我不认为有人留着它们。我没留。你留了吗？我不知道我们可以留。我可能本来会拿一个。那是早期，我们还没胆量要求拿东西。是的，不。后来剧集结束时，我拿了帕姆的日常包。那只是放在那儿的东西，即使我没在场景里用过，它也放在
on Pam's desk or it was in her drawer. So I have that. I have Pam's everyday purse that she had for most of the season. But I didn't keep a fancy purse. There's this scene where Michael has to refer to Katie the Purse Girl as Pam 6.0. This was not an improvisation. I have the script. I know.
帕姆的桌子上或者在她的抽屉里。所以我留着那个。我有帕姆大部分时间用的日常包。但我没留高级包。有一个场景，迈克尔不得不把凯蒂这个“手提包女孩”称为“帕姆6.0”。这不是即兴表演。我有剧本。我知道。
From Hot Girl. I have all the scripts from season one. I saved them, speaking of saving things. And I looked it up. She is like the improved version of me. Like she is. She is not. improved version of me. Like she is. Like, yes she is. She is not.
来自《Hot Girl》。我有第一季所有的剧本。我保存了它们，说到保存东西。我查了一下。她就像是我的改进版。就像她是。她不是。我的改进版。就像她是。就像，是的她是。她不是。
She is. But as your best friend, I am not gonna let that slide. She is not. But in this episode, they had really zhuzhed her up. She had a pushup bra on and her hair off. It doesn't matter. Even on our plainest day, Amy Adams is Jenna 6.0. She is.
她是。但作为你最好的朋友，我不会让它溜走。她不是。但在这一集中，他们真的把她打扮得很漂亮。她戴着聚拢胸罩，头发散着。没关系。即使在我们最朴素的日子里，艾米·亚当斯也是珍娜6.0。她是。
No, she's not. It's okay with me. No, I'm not, no. Well, okay, well, whatever. Should I have not said that? No, I think it's a funny story. But as your best friend, I'm not gonna let you say Amy Adams is a better version of you. It's like we look similar,
不，她不是。我没关系。不，我不是，不。嗯，好吧，嗯，随便吧。我不该那么说吗？不，我觉得这是一个有趣的故事。但作为你最好的朋友，我不会让你说艾米·亚当斯是你的更好版本。就像我们看起来很像，
but then her nose is a little daintier, and her cheeks are a little rosier, and her hair is just a little brighter red. You know what I'm saying? It's just like she just turn it up a couple of notches on the dial and you get Amy Adams. Like if you're creating me, right, you get to me. And then if you turn the dial a couple more notches,
但她的鼻子更精致一点，脸颊更红润一点，头发是更亮一点的红色。你知道我在说什么吗？就像她只是把刻度调高了几档，你就得到了艾米·亚当斯。就像如果你在创造我，对吧，你得到了我。然后如果你把刻度再调高几档，
it turns into Amy Adams. She's Disney you. She kind of is. She's the Disney princess version of me. Yes. Angela, do you have a note card? Because you're like handling a note card right now. I feel like you want to say a note card.
就变成了艾米·亚当斯。她是迪士尼版的你。她有点像。她是我的迪士尼公主版。是的。安吉拉，你有笔记卡吗？因为你现在拿着一张笔记卡。我觉得你想说一张笔记卡。
I mean, I have a- It's in your hand and then you're touching them. What is it that you want to say? Are you annoyed that I'm touching your note card? No, I'm giving you a chance to speak. Oh. Thank you so much. Oh, so it's British when you were offended. Oh, God. No, stop.
我的意思是，我有一张……它在你手里，然后你在摸它们。你想说什么？你是因为我在摸你的笔记卡而烦恼吗？不，我是在给你说话的机会。哦。太感谢了。哦，所以当你被冒犯时就是英国口音。哦，天哪。不，停下。
Stop. I was just going to say that Michael Scott has a talking head that I love so much. And these are just one of these talking heads that they're in every episode. And getting to re-watch them, I'm like, ah, my God, that's brilliant. Is it the small businessman?
停下。我只是想说迈克尔·斯科特有一个我非常喜欢的采访镜头。这些只是每一集里都有的采访镜头之一。重温它们时，我心想，啊，天哪，太精彩了。是那个小商人吗？
I love that he- Is it the things that he reads? I love that he said he loves American Way magazine, the In--flight magazine. And then he goes, they did a great profile on Doris Roberts and where she likes to eat when she's in Phoenix. It just made me laugh so hard because I read those. I just want you to know American Airlines, whenever I'm fly with you, I get the American
我喜欢他……是那些他读的东西吗？我喜欢他说他喜欢《美国之路》杂志，那本机上杂志。然后他说，他们对多丽丝·罗伯茨做了一个很棒的专题，关于她在凤凰城时喜欢去哪儿吃饭。这让我笑得太厉害了，因为我也读那些。我只是想让你知道美国航空，每当我坐你们的飞机时，我都会拿出《美国之路》
Way out and I look to see where people eat. It made me laugh so hard. And then he's like, illuminating. I love those magazines too. I read them. And you know, actually one of the coolest things that ever happened to me is that one time I had an article in- In an Inflate magazine? Yes, just like the Doris Roberts thing I got profiled.
看人们去哪儿吃饭。这让我笑得太厉害了。然后他说，很有启发性。我也喜欢那些杂志。我读它们。而且你知道，实际上发生在我身上最酷的事情之一就是有一次我有一篇文章在……在机上杂志里？是的，就像多丽丝·罗伯茨那个专题一样，我被报道了。
What? I would be so excited. Why didn't you tell me? That is so cool. No, I told this story about playing poker in Scotland. Oh, wait, wait. I know this is a total tangent. Guys, I'm sorry. I have to take Jenna on a tangent because I love this story. Yeah. Should I tell the story?
什么？我会非常兴奋。你为什么不告诉我？那太酷了。不，我讲了这个关于在苏格兰玩扑克的故事。哦，等等，等等。我知道这是一个完全的题外话。伙计们，抱歉。我必须带珍娜走个题外话，因为我喜欢这个故事。是的。我应该讲这个故事吗？
You have to tell it. Okay. Because first of all, it makes you sound way cooler than you are. No offense. I know. But it kind of makes you sound like a rock star. It's my biggest rock star moment of my life. It's pretty-
你必须讲。好的。因为首先，它让你听起来比你实际酷得多。没冒犯的意思。我知道。但它让你听起来有点像摇滚明星。这是我一生中最大的摇滚明星时刻。它相当……
100%. Okay. So I had no way. I know you're going to tell that story, but I need to see that in-flight magazine article. I'll show it to you. It was for United magazine. Okay. And they had this story where they wanted people to tell the craziest ways they've ever fought jet lag. Okay. So Lee and I had this little romantic trip that we took to Scotland. This was before we had children. I remember this because you told me you were going and I was like, romantic trip that we took to Scotland. This was before we had children. I remember this because you told me you were going and I was like, well, that's not a lot
100%。好的。所以我没法……我知道你要讲那个故事，但我需要看那本机上杂志的文章。我会给你看的。那是为联合航空杂志写的。好的。他们有一个故事，想让人们讲述他们克服时差的最疯狂的方法。好的。所以李和我有一个小小的浪漫旅行，我们去了苏格兰。这是在我们有孩子之前。我记得这个，因为你告诉我你要去，我说，我们去了苏格兰的浪漫旅行。这是在我们有孩子之前。我记得这个，因为你告诉我你要去，我说，嗯，那没几天。
of days. Yeah, we only had five days because we had a one week hiatus from work. This is what people without children can do. Yeah, we can just jet off to Scotland for five days. So we were going to spend two days in Edinburgh. Okay. And then we were going to go into the countryside for the other three days, do a tour of a, you know, like a Scotch factory and everything. Really fun. So we get there and we thought we will take an overnight flight. We will sleep on the plane and we will arrive at noon rested and ready to tour Edinburgh.
是的，我们只有五天，因为我们有一周的工作间歇。这就是没有孩子的人能做的事。是的，我们可以直接飞去苏格兰五天。所以我们打算在爱丁堡待两天。好的。然后我们打算去乡村待剩下的三天，参观一家，你知道，像苏格兰威士忌工厂之类的。真的很有趣。所以我们到了那儿，我们想我们会坐夜班飞机。我们会在飞机上睡觉，然后我们会在中午到达，休息好并准备好游览爱丁堡。
Yeah, right. This did not happen. We did not sleep on the plane. And we landed, it was noon, and we were thinking, how in the world are we going to make it through this whole day? We were exhausted. We were so tired. We're touring a castle. We're walking along little shops.
是啊，没错。这事儿根本没发生。我们在飞机上根本没睡。我们落地时是中午，当时就在想，我们到底要怎么熬过这一整天？我们精疲力竭。我们太累了。我们去参观城堡，在小店里逛来逛去。
We bought some hats and at a little hat shop. Wait, I know, I know I'm raising my hand because Because Jenna, you texted me, and I remember you saying, we're so tired, we're going to try to power through. We're going to try to power through so we don't fall asleep. Yes. You can't fall asleep in the middle of the day. Then you're ruined. No.
我们在一家小帽子店买了几顶帽子。等等，我知道，我知道我举手是因为……因为珍娜，你给我发了短信，我记得你说，我们太累了，我们要试着硬撑过去。我们要试着硬撑，这样就不会睡着。是的。你不能在大白天睡着。不然你就全完了。不。
The whole five days, you're just going to be sleeping during the day and up at night. So it's 5 o'clock, and we are so exhausted, just so incredibly exhausted. We thought, here's what we're going to do. We're going to go into a little pub. We're going to get a bite to eat. We're going to have a drink.
接下来的五天，你只会白天睡觉，晚上清醒。所以到了5点，我们已经筋疲力尽，简直累得不行。我们想，我们得这么做。我们要进一家小酒吧，吃点东西，喝上一杯。
We are going to force ourselves to stay awake until 7 p.m. and then we're going to go back to the hotel and fall asleep. Right. That was your plan. Go to the pub, power through and then go to bed. Correct. We get to the pub, we order our drink, and we see a sign that says,
我们要强迫自己撑到晚上7点，然后回酒店睡觉。对。那是你们的计划。去酒吧，硬撑着，然后去睡觉。没错。我们到了酒吧，点了酒，然后看到一个牌子写着：
Poker Tournament, starting at 6 p.m. All right, I have to interject here. So my BFF, Jenna Fischer, is a flippin' fantastic poker player. I don't know if I'm fantastic, but I love playing. You are fantastic. Okay, no, you're fantastic. And I once went with her to the Celebrity Poker Showdown,
扑克锦标赛，晚上6点开始。好吧，我得插一句。我的闺蜜，珍娜·费舍尔，是个超级厉害的扑克玩家。我不知道我算不算厉害，但我很爱玩。你就是很厉害。好吧，不，你才厉害。我曾经和她一起去参加过名人扑克对决，
story for later, but she's really good at poker. I came in second place. You came in, I mean that's- Behind Keegan-Michael Key, he won. That's a big flex, cause you beat Michael Ian Black, who still tells me that you beat him in poker. And I mean, you guys, I-
故事以后再说，但她扑克真的打得很好。我得了第二名。你得了，我是说那是——在基根-迈克尔·凯之后，他赢了。那可是个大炫耀，因为你打败了迈克尔·伊恩·布莱克，他到现在还跟我说你扑克赢了他。我是说，你们这些家伙，我——
I also just wanna say, all of this is before I had children. Yeah. I barely play poker anymore. I can't stay awake for anything. I know, but you are really good. Back in your day, lady. Back in the day.
我也想说，这一切都是在我有孩子之前。是啊。我现在几乎不打扑克了。我什么都撑不住了。我知道，但你真的很厉害。那是你的黄金时代，女士。那是过去的事了。
Back in your day before kids. In my youth. In your youth, you were quite the poker player. I think I can win poker with like two pairs of threes. And I have all the bravado. Two pairs of threes. That would be four of a kind. You can.
在你有了孩子之前的黄金时代。在我的青春岁月里。在你的青春岁月里，你可是个扑克高手。我觉得我能用两对三之类的牌赢扑克。而且我表现得很有底气。两对三。那可是四条。你可以的。
You can win poker with that, Angela. OK, so see, this is the problem. But I have no idea what I'm doing. And I think sometimes I mess up a table just because I have such confidence and I have nothing. And then people are like, okay. Sometimes that's the best strategy. Okay, go. You're in Scotland. You're trying to stay awake. So tired. We sign up for the poker tournament. Lee, my husband, he plays poker as well. We're thinking, here's what we'll do. We'll join the poker tournament at 6 p.m. We'll be done at 7.
安吉拉，你可以用那个赢扑克。好吧，你看，这就是问题所在。但我根本不知道自己在干什么。我觉得有时候我能搅乱牌局，仅仅是因为我表现得很有自信，其实我手里什么都没有。然后大家就会想，好吧。有时候那是最好的策略。好吧，继续。你在苏格兰。你正努力保持清醒。太累了。我们报名参加了扑克锦标赛。我丈夫李也打扑克。我们想，我们就这么办。我们参加晚上6点的扑克锦标赛。7点就能结束。
This is how we're going to stay awake that extra hour. You're going to play an hour of poker and then you're going to go to bed. Go to bed. We enter the tournament. We start playing. We start winning. You're like the two Americans who came in and now you're kicking butt in this pub in Scotland.
这就是我们保持清醒多撑一小时的方法。你要打一小时扑克，然后去睡觉。去睡觉。我们参加了比赛。开始打牌。我们开始赢了。你们就像那两个突然冒出来的美国人，现在正在苏格兰的这家酒吧里大杀四方。
So much so that we make it to the final table. What time is this? How long have you been there now? It is now midnight. Oh, Jenna. We are out of our minds. Exhausted. I don't even know what I'm doing.
以至于我们打进了决赛桌。现在几点了？你们在那儿待了多久了？现在是午夜。哦，珍娜。我们都快疯了。精疲力竭。我甚至不知道自己在干什么。
It's probably why I was doing so well. Because you're so loopy. You're playing the best poker of your life. Lee and I are both at the final table and we keep checking in with each other saying like, should we quit? A couple times Lee went all in because he's like, I'm so tired, just all in and he would win. Finally, I get down to the final two.
这可能就是我表现得那么好的原因。因为你脑子都糊涂了。你正在打出你人生中最棒的扑克。我和李都在决赛桌，我们不停地互相确认，说，我们要退出吗？有几次李全押了，因为他说，我太累了，直接全押吧，结果他赢了。最后，我进入了两人对决。
It's 2 a.m. And it's you and one other person? One local Scottish guy. Fella. Who played every week in the tournament. And here you are. This American. Tired person. On her vacation.
凌晨2点了。就你和另外一个人？一个当地的苏格兰人。那个家伙。他每周都参加这个比赛。而你就在这儿。这个美国人。疲惫不堪的人。在度假。
And I won. You won the whole thing! I won! I won the whole thing. I won 200 pounds. Wow! Amazing. Leigh and I couldn't believe it.
然后我赢了。你赢了整场比赛！我赢了！我赢了整场比赛。我赢了200英镑。哇！太棒了。李和我简直不敢相信。
Everyone in the pub was a little bit like, yay. Yay for her. And did you get your name like up on the wall or something? Yes. I got my name up on the leaderboard and I was supposed to come back for the championship like table that was happening in several months. Of course, we all knew I wasn't going to show up. So I think the runner up guy got to take my place. And then we went back to the hotel and we slept so well and I suffered no jet
酒吧里的每个人都有点像，耶。为她欢呼。你的名字被写在墙上之类的了吗？是的。我的名字被写在了排行榜上，我本应该几个月后回来参加冠军赛的。当然，我们都知道我不会去。所以我认为亚军代替了我的位置。然后我们回到酒店，睡得特别香，在那次旅行的剩余时间里，我完全没有时差反应。
leg for the rest of that trip. So this was the story in the United magazine. And I was so proud to be in that magazine. I'm with Michael Scott. That would have been a heck of a read. I got copies. I sent them to my mom. I sent them to my in-laws. I have one at home. I want you guys to know, I woke up back here in the US of A, and I had a text from my best friend in Scotland, and there was a photo of her in a pub. Wearing my hat that I had bought, by the way. Wearing your hat.
所以这就是《联合航空》杂志上的故事。我为能登上那本杂志感到非常自豪。我和迈克尔·斯科特在一起。那一定是一篇很棒的读物。我拿到了副本。我寄给了我妈妈。我寄给了我的姻亲。我家里还有一本。我想让你们知道，我回到美国后醒来，收到了一条来自我在苏格兰最好的朋友的短信，照片里她在酒吧里。顺便说一下，戴着我买的那顶帽子。戴着你的帽子。
My wool hat. And like smiling, and I was like, what is going on? And you were like, I want a poker tournament. I was like, you're supposed to be sleeping. Yeah, but that's, I mean, truly that is like maybe one of my proudest moments. Yeah, that's a pretty rockstar moment, lady. Thank you.
我的羊毛帽。而且在笑，我就想，这是怎么回事？你说，我赢了一场扑克锦标赛。我说，你不是应该在睡觉吗？是啊，但那是，我是说，那真的是我最自豪的时刻之一。是啊，那真是个摇滚明星般的时刻，女士。谢谢。
Well, we should probably get back to the episode. This is the cringiest episode of The Office so far. Not ever, I mean, Scott's Tots, but. It's cringy, but diversity day is pretty cringy too. But the whole scene where Michael is talking to Katie about coffee. I was dying. Oh, I was dying. What I was also got so weirded out when he was like, you know, I'm trying to do here is just break down walls. I just tried to break down walls. I was like, what
好吧，我们大概该回到剧集了。这是《办公室》目前为止最让人尴尬的一集。不是史上最尴尬，我是说《斯科特的托特们》，但是。这很尴尬，但《多元化日》也挺尴尬的。但迈克尔和凯蒂谈论咖啡的整个场景。我快笑死了。哦，我快笑死了。当他说，你知道，我在这里试图做的是打破隔阂。我只是试图打破隔阂。我当时想，他在说什么？
is he talking about? Oh my goodness. And she plays it so well. Oh my gosh. She does. And then that scene with Brian over my shoulder asking me if I'm jealous. I laughed so hard during that scene. What was difficult was that I was supposed to sit there and be doing my work and he is hovering over me and then insulting me. And I could not get through it. Every time he would start his sentence, it would make me laugh.
天哪。她演得真好。天哪。她确实演得好。还有布莱恩在我肩后问我是否嫉妒的那一幕。那一幕我笑得好厉害。困难的是，我本该坐在那里做我的工作，而他在我上方盘旋，然后侮辱我。我根本演不下去。每次他开始说话，我就会笑场。
That was a scene that I probably laughed the most in when I was shooting this episode. And this leads me into a fan question from Delaney. Did you guys ever get offended by the scripts personally, like in this episode, how Pam has compared to Katie the whole time? Jenna, did you take that personally? I didn't.
那是我拍摄这一集时笑得最多的一场戏。这引出了德莱尼的一个粉丝提问。你们有没有因为剧本而感到个人被冒犯，比如在这一集中，帕姆一直被拿来和凯蒂比较？珍娜，你介意吗？我没有。
Well, I didn't. Well, I didn't either because I felt like a lot of our comedy was, it was a little bit of a free for all. Everyone was going to have a moment where they were sort of the butt of the joke. But it was never malicious. It served the script. It served the story.
嗯，我没有。嗯，我也没有，因为我觉得我们的很多喜剧，有点像是一场混战。每个人都会有成为笑柄的时候。但这从来不是恶意的。这是为了剧本服务。这是为了故事服务。
I never took offense. Also, I feel like so much of comedy and comedians is self-deprecating in nature. And so we're a group of people who are pretty honest with ourselves. Don't you think? It wasn't offensive to me. It was the idea that has happened to all of us where a more attractive person walks in the room and is getting all the attention and then you feel you feel jealous. But I enjoyed this episode. I loved playing with all those feelings.
我从不觉得被冒犯。而且，我觉得喜剧和喜剧演员的很大一部分本质是自嘲。所以我们是一群对自己很诚实的人。你不觉得吗？这对我来说并不冒犯。这是一种我们所有人都经历过的想法，当一个更有吸引力的人走进房间，吸引了所有人的注意，然后你会感到嫉妒。但我很喜欢这一集。我很喜欢演绎所有这些感受。
I was going to say it was a lot of human moments for Pam just seeing how Jim was affected and how that affected her and it was fantastic. I thought you did an excellent job. I have on one of my note cards. Where is it Jenna? What does it say? Jenna was brilliant. She was. Thank you, Angela. You were so good. Oh, I don't want to like get us off your, I know you have your list lady,
我正想说，这对帕姆来说有很多展现人性的时刻，看到吉姆受到了怎样的影响，以及这如何影响了她，这太棒了。我觉得你做得非常出色。我的笔记卡上写着。在哪儿呢，珍娜？上面写着什么？珍娜太棒了。她确实很棒。谢谢你，安吉拉。你演得真好。哦，我不想让我们偏离你的，我知道你有你的清单，女士，
but the moment when she's like, what are you going to do? And he's like, oh, I think actually I'm going to see Katie. The look on your face as Pam, what you did with your eyes in that moment was so amazing. It was so amazing. It's interesting. You know what I gave myself as a direction in that moment in my head? What? Was when he tells you that, do not blink your eyes. Just stare at him. You're not affected
但当她说，你打算怎么办？而他说，哦，我想其实我要去见凯蒂。你作为帕姆脸上的表情，那一刻你眼神的演绎真是太神奇了。太神奇了。这很有趣。你知道我在那一刻脑子里给自己设定的指导是什么吗？什么？就是当他告诉你那个消息时，不要眨眼。就盯着他看。你没有受到
by that and smile because that is great news. Oh, that's great. That was her way of trying to not show how she was feeling, but then show it shows everything. Yeah, it showed everything. It was so great. The scene with Katie, Michael, and Toby. Oh, brutal. Oh, Jenna, I watched the deleted scenes this time. You did?
那个消息的影响，并且微笑，因为那是好消息。哦，那太棒了。那是她试图掩饰自己感受的方式，但随后它展现了一切。是的，它展现了一切。太棒了。凯蒂、迈克尔和托比的那场戏。哦，太残忍了。哦，珍娜，我这次看了删减片段。你看了？
Yes, so I still haven't gotten a DVD player. How'd you do it? I found them online. OK. I don't know if it was a legal site that I went to. I clicked on so many things that took me there. So I don them online. Okay. I don't know if it was a legal site that I went to. I clicked on so many things that took me there. So I don't know. I probably have some inappropriate things on my computer now.
是的，所以我还没买DVD播放机。你是怎么看的？我在网上找到了。好吧。我不知道我访问的是不是合法网站。我点击了太多东西才找到那里。所以我不知道。我的电脑里现在可能有一些不合适的东西。
Oh, boy. No, I'm just saying I clicked away. But anyway, I watched the deleted scenes and there is a longer version of that scene where Steve I know is just riffing on that whole idea of sad, sack Toby. And it just, it is so cringy. Oh, I wanna go back and watch that. It's really good. So what you see in the episode is just like
哦，天哪。不，我只是说我点开了。但不管怎样，我看了删减片段，那一幕有一个更长的版本，史蒂夫我知道他只是在即兴发挥关于那个悲惨的托比的想法。这太尴尬了。哦，我想回去看看。真的很好。所以你在剧集中看到的只是
three seconds of that moment where he's like, oh yeah, your divorce, right? Sleeping in your car. I loved the, you slept one night in your car, right? Made me laugh out loud. Yeah, so good. For a long time. Yeah, and Paul's me laugh out loud. Yeah, so good. For a long time. Yeah, and Paul's
那三秒钟，他说，哦，对了，你离婚了，对吧？睡在车里。我喜欢那个，你有一晚睡在车里，对吧？让我大笑出声。是啊，太好了。很长一段时间。是啊，保罗的反应太完美了。在删减片段里，迈克尔对他喋喋不休了好几分钟。最神奇的是，史蒂夫和保罗在现实生活中都是那种非常温柔、安静、善良的人。他们不得不，好吧，我想只是迈克尔不得不欺负托比。但史蒂夫和保罗现实生活中的关系完全相反。是啊，不，但那是，哦，凯蒂说，我在哪儿？噢，我有一些金西的小花絮。好吧，让我们听听。
reaction is so perfect. In the deleted scenes, Michael goes off on him for like minutes. What's so amazing is that Steve and Paul in real life are both of our kind of very gentle, quiet, kind people on the set. And they have to, well, I guess just Michael has to bully Toby. But Stephen Paul's real life relationship is so opposite that. Yeah, no, but it was, oh, and Katie's like, where am I? Ooh, I have some Kinsey tidbits. All right, let's hear them.
在8分14秒，你，帕姆，气冲冲地从罗伊身边站起来，把沙拉留在了桌子上。是啊。你留下了你的，你没收拾你的特百惠餐盒什么的，你还有一个果汁盒。你是怎么，我刚刚被侮辱了。他侮辱了我。他刚刚说我们在约会，我不得不说，我们不是在约会，我们订婚了。我很受伤。
At eight minutes, 14 seconds, you, Pam, gets up in a huff from Roy and leaves her salad on the table. Yeah. You left your, you didn't pack up your Tupperware or anything and you had a juice box. What are you, I was just been, I had just been insulted. He insulted me. He just, he just said we're dating and I had to say, we're not dating, we're engaged. I'm very hurt.
然后我走开了。你想要什么？这是我的沙拉和特百惠，你自己处理吧。你从来没有在吃饭时被冒犯然后直接离开餐桌吗？没有。所以如果你在晚餐时和某人吵架，你会带着盘子站起来，去把它冲洗干净放进洗碗机里。
And I walk away. What do you want? And here's my salad and my Tupperware, deal with it. Have you never been at a meal and been offended and just left your plate? No. So if you're in a fight with someone over dinner, you get up with your plate and you go rinse it off and put it in the dishwasher.
没错，我会把盘子洗了，我不会留下我的沙拉。我很想看看那个。我觉得如果她——我很想看看那个。哦，好吧。我觉得如果她把食物带走会很奇怪。真是个奇怪的选择。我觉得是，我觉得如果她气疯了还得打包沙拉会很有趣。我有一件事想分享关于帕姆和罗伊的订婚戒指。道具组，当你在剧中要结婚时，他们会带给你一整盘戒指。让你选。是的，你可以选，在剧中，他们会带给你一整盘戒指。科琳·奥布莱恩：是的，去选。索尼娅·达拉：是的，你可以选择你的订婚戒指和结婚戒指。现在，这些是基于
That's right, I'm gonna bust my plate, I'm not gonna leave my salad. I would love to see that. I think it would have been so weird if she I would love to see that. Oh, well. I think it would have been so weird if she had taken her food with her. What an odd choice. I thought it was, I think it would be funny
导演和制片人预先筛选过的选择，对吧？所以你不能随便选一个巨大的戒指。科琳·奥布莱恩：没错，它必须符合你角色的生活。索尼娅·达拉：是的，但他们会给你各种各样的选择，你必须试戴不同尺寸的。所以当他们给我那盘戒指时，我选了一个钻石簇戒，而不是单颗钻石戒指。我心里想的是帕姆
if she was mad as hell and had to pack up her salad. I have a thing that I wanted to share about Pam's engagement ring to Roy. The props people, when you have to be married on a show, they'll bring you a whole tray of rings. To pick. Yes, you get to pick your on a show, they'll bring you a whole tray of rings. COLLEEN O'BRIEN Yes, to pick. SONIA DARA Yes, you get to pick your engagement ring and your wedding ring. Now, these are based on selections
一直很受伤，因为罗伊没有给她更多她想要的戒指，那应该是更像单颗钻石的戒指，更像吉姆后来会给她的那种。但她是个有礼貌的人，她认为因为戒指而感到被冒犯或不喜欢戒指是不对的，所以她必须非常优雅地接受这个戒指。但我一直觉得她对罗伊的看法是，他没有花足够的精力去了解她或她喜欢什么，或者他在订婚戒指上没有花太多心思。或者这段关系。
that have been pre-edited by the director and producers, right? So you can't just pick like a honkin' ring. COLLEEN O'BRIEN Right, it has to match your character's life. SONIA DARA Yes, but they give you a variety of things to choose from and you have to try them on in different sizes. So when they gave me the tray of rings, I picked a diamond cluster ring as opposed to a diamond solitaire. And I had it in my mind that Pam
或者这段关系，但戒指确实是他缺乏努力和不了解她的象征。每天当我低头看着那个钻石簇戒时，它只会刺痛她在与罗伊的关系中所受的伤。所以当他说，女朋友，那是她觉得，没错。这个戒指让我觉得我们没有订婚。我已经戴了这个钻石簇戒三年了，它感觉就像是你给女朋友的东西。它感觉不像你求婚时给人的东西，至少对帕姆来说是这样。这有道理吗？
has always been hurt that Roy didn't get her more of the ring she wanted, which would be more of a diamond solitaire, more of what Jim is going to give her later. But she's a polite person and she thinks it's not right to be offended by the ring or to not like the ring, so she had to very graciously accept this ring. But I always felt like her opinion of Roy was that he didn't put enough effort into getting to know her or what she would like, or he didn't put a lot of effort into the engagement ring. Or the relationship.
有道理。而且这让我感到难过。现在我收回我的沙拉。我对沙拉的评价。所以你看到了她有多受伤。你看到了其中的历史。在那一刻，她没法去清理沙拉，安吉拉。是啊，不，在那一刻，她想的是，三年。
Or the relationship, but that the ring is really a symbol of his lack of effort and his lack of knowing her. And every day when I would look down at that diamond clustering, it would just poke at those wounds that she has in her relationship with Roy. And so when he says, boyfriend, that's another way that she's like, that's right. This ring makes me feel like we're not engaged. I've been wearing this diamond cluster ring for three years and it feels like a thing that you give your girlfriend. It doesn't feel like what you give someone when you're proposing, at least for Pam. Does that make sense?
三年了，我坐在这里，你却没注意到我。这就是她内心愤怒的原因。这可能是帕姆有过的最大的一次受伤和愤怒的展示。是啊。她没有发泄出来。不。好吧。我收回关于沙拉的话。
It does. And it also just makes me sad. And now I take back my salad. My salad judgment. So you see how hurt she was. You see the history there. She can't clean up a salad in that moment, Angela. Yeah, no, in that moment, she's like, three years.
谢谢。打包。好吧。非常感谢。但你想向我解释一下为什么在9分23秒，ET又回到了吉姆的桌子上吗？哇。是啊。23秒。ET回到了吉姆的桌子上。哇。是啊。
Three years I've sat here and you haven't noticed me. That's what's raging inside her. And this is probably one of the biggest displays of hurt and anger that Pam has ever had. Yeah. She doesn't let it out. No. Okay. I take back the salad.
ET穿着他的蓝色长袍，回到了吉姆的桌子上。所以他先是在桌子上，然后又不在了。哦，萨姆要提起ET了。他们在看，所以我提出建议。等着瞧。事情是这样的，好吗？你继续说。看到ET了吗？
Thank you. Packing up. Okay. Thank you very much. But do you want to explain to me why at nine minutes, 23 seconds, ET is back on Jim's desk? Wow. Yeah. 23 seconds. ET is back on Jim's desk. Wow. Yeah.
看到ET了吗？在哪儿，在哪儿？哦，是的！哦，是的！哦，是的，是的，我看到了，我看到了。那是什么？我不知道。我们需要从约翰那里查清楚。还有菲尔·谢。我们会给约翰和菲尔发短信，得到答案。我有一个粉丝提问。
ET in his blue robe, back on Jim's desk. So he was on the desk and then off. Oh, Sam's gonna bring up ET. They're looking at, so I make suggestions. Wait for it. Here's the thing, okay? You just keep talking. See ET?
这是玛丽·贝丝问的。德怀特和凯蒂谈论买钱包时，吉姆和帕姆开始尴尬地解说互动的场景，那是剧本写的，还是约翰和珍娜只是顺着雷恩决定做的事情演的？那是即兴表演。我们在片场，我们有一个小剧本场景，然后有人建议我们解说正在发生的事情。
See ET? Where, where? Oh yeah! Oh yeah! Oh yes, yes, I see it, I see it. What is that? I don't know. We need to find out from John. And Phil Shea. We will text John and Phil and get an answer. I have a fan question.
我想那是约翰的主意。所以雷恩知道我们要那么做。于是他开始用钱包做各种疯狂的事情，比如把它摔在桌子上，试图把它放进，是的，没错，给我们一些奇怪的事情说。我真的僵住了。我不擅长喜剧、即兴表演、小品喜剧。我上过几门那样的课，但我总是演得很烂。
This is from Mary Beth. The scene where Dwight is talking to Katie about buying a purse when Jim and Pam start awkwardly narrating the interaction, was that scene scripted or did John and Jenna just play off whatever Rain decided to do? It was improvised. We were on set and we had a little scripted scene and then it was suggested that we narrate what was going on.
我僵住了。我非常擅长在特定角色中进行即兴表演，但如果这个特定角色必须搞笑并说出聪明的话，那就不行了。那不是我的强项。没关系，女士。我知道你很擅长。你，那是你的拿手好戏。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。为了让我们回到剧情，在这一集的这一点上，迈克尔买了一台星巴克咖啡机。1000美元。
I think it was John's idea. So Rain knew that we were gonna do that. So he started doing all kinds of crazy stuff with the purses, like slamming it on the desk and like trying to put it, yes, exactly, to give us weird things to say. And I really froze. I am not a great improviser in like comedy, improv, sketch comedy. I took a couple of those classes and I always really tanked.
1000美元。这将是给销售额最高的销售员的奖励。但随后他拆开包装，给“第一个女孩”凯蒂倒了一杯咖啡。他用这个咖啡机来调情，真是太令人毛骨悚然了。他用它真的很恶心。
I froze. I'm very good at improvising in a specific character, but not if the specific character has to be funny and say clever things. That's not my forte. It's okay, lady. I know you're good at it. You, that was your thing. I love it. I love it. Just to keep us on plot, at this point in the episode, Michael buys a Starbucks coffee machine. $1,000.
不过我喜欢他的台词，他说，80年代的邓德·米夫林，在他们知道可卡因有多糟糕之前。天哪，他们卖纸卖得真快。他们卖纸。太搞笑了。我喜欢那句台词。我还记得迈克尔和德怀特的场景。
$1,000. This is going to be the incentive for the salesperson who sells the most. But then he unwraps it and makes Katie the First Girl a cup of coffee. He's so creepy that he's used this coffee thing to flirt with her. He's so creepy with it.
迈克尔告诉德怀特他要送凯蒂回家，德怀特问他是否爱她。你爱她吗？你爱她吗？我记得他们在那场戏里一直笑场。他们俩一直在逗对方笑。这持续了很久。我不止喜欢德怀特问“你爱她吗？”
I love his line, though, where he says, Dunder Mifflin in the 80s, before they knew how bad cocaine was. Man, did they move paper. They moved paper. So funny. I love that line. I also remember the scene with Michael and Dwight.
我喜欢迈克尔说，我不知道。也许，我不知道。我说不准。我还没决定。哦，我不知道。他们俩太荒谬了。然后是罗伊，他决定要试着和帕姆和好。
Michael tells Dwight that he's going to be giving Katie a ride home and Dwight asking if he loves her. Do you love her? Do you love her? I remember they could not get through that scene. The two of them were cracking each other up. It went on forever. Not only do I love that Dwight is like, do you love her?
他决定在你坐在吉姆桌子上时开始挠你痒痒。太尴尬了。就在吉姆旁边。我记得拍摄那场戏。当我观看它时，我为吉姆感到非常不舒服。我当时想，哦，上帝，吉姆。然后他站起来走开了。是的。
I love that Michael's like, I don't know. Maybe, I don't know. I can't say. I don't know yet. Oh, I don't know. The two of them are ridiculous. And then you have Roy who decides he's gonna try to make up with Pam.
关于这一点，有一件有趣的事。作为珍娜，我讨厌被挠痒痒。是啊，你讨厌它。我不喜欢。这绝对不是和我和好的方式。这会让你生气。会的。是啊。我会说，不。我想当我拍摄那场戏时，我必须真正理解一个事实，
And he decides to start tickling you while you're sitting on Jim's desk. So awkward. Next to Jim. I remember filming that scene. When I watched it, I felt so uncomfortable for Jim. I was like, Oh God, Jim. And then he gets up and he walks away. Yes.
这是珍娜和帕姆不同的地方。是啊。帕姆被它打动了。帕姆说，哦，得了吧。哦，不。这就是他们和好的方式。帕姆和罗伊在那一刻之后又成了朋友，或者我想是又订婚了。不管他们是什么，他们又在一起了。不管他们是什么，他们又在一起了。但作为珍娜，我必须真正压抑我所有的珍娜本能，因为我不喜欢挠痒痒。
So here's something interesting about that. I as Jenna, hate being tickled. Yeah, you hate it. I don't like it. It is not. It certainly would not be the way to make up with me. It would make you angry. It would. Yeah. I would be like, no. And I think that when I was filming that, I had to really wrap my head around the fact,
嗯，有些人确实非常不喜欢被挠痒痒。我不喜欢被吓到。哦，我知道。嗯，我丈夫，每年万圣节前后。你不喜欢被惊吓。我不喜欢恐怖电影。你反应不好。我不去看恐怖电影。我爸爸也是这样。
this is a way that Jenna and Pam are different. Yeah. Pam is won over by it. Pam is like, oh, come on. Oh, no. That is how they make up. Pam and Roy are friends again, or I guess engaged again after that moment. Whatever they are, they're back. Whatever they are, they're back. But for me as Jenna, I had to really stuff all of my Jenna instincts because I do not like tickling.
所以你知道人们常说的“战斗或逃跑”吗？是啊。我是战斗。所以乔什，我丈夫，万圣节前后，他和孩子们觉得拿个假手臂或面具吓唬我很有趣。我总是对他们说，你们其中一个会被揍的。你们知道的。而且我没有——人们吓你时你会挥舞手臂。是啊。我见过这种情况。我无法控制它。就在最近，我丈夫，万圣节时，他们跳出来吓我，戴着这个面具，我尖叫起来。然后我用尽全力，把手机扔向他。我用手机打了他。
Well, and some people really don't like being tickled. I don't like being scared. Oh, I know. Well, and my husband, like once a year around Halloween. You don't like being startled or scared. I don't like scary movies. You don't respond well. I don't go to scary movies. And my dad was the same way.
显然，我不是故意的。这只是那种奇怪的本能反应，我只会说，啊！是啊。你得希望你永远不需要拍那种有人吓你的戏。那会非常……因为你会……你怎么能让你的手臂不挥舞呢？我不知道。我不知道。有人会受伤的。那是我在那场戏中的困难，因为挠我痒痒让我很烦躁。想揍人？
So you know how they say some people are like fight or flight? Yeah. I am fight. And so Josh, my husband, like around Halloween, him and the kids think it's funny to get like a fake arm or a mask and scare me. And I always say to them, one of you will get whacked. You know that. And I have no- You flail your arms when people scare you. Yeah. I've seen it happen. I have no control over it. Just recently, my husband, for Halloween, they jumped out to scare me, had this mask on and I screamed. And then with everything I had, I hooked my phone at him. And I hit him with my phone.
并不会让我笑。嗯，我觉得你做得很好，而且尴尬得要命。可怜的吉姆。我知道。好吧，我们要去休息一下。休息一下。音乐：安吉拉，我想先问你一个问题。好的。你知道德怀特邀请凯蒂约会的场景，就在你角色面前，因为你在看钱包？那一刻你的表情，你在想什么？
Clearly, like I didn't mean to. It's just like this weird instinctual thing where I just go, ah! Yeah. You need to hope that you never have to do a scene where someone scares you. It'll be very... Because you will... How will you keep your arms from not whacking? I don't know. I don't know. Someone will get hurt. That was the difficulty for me in that scene because tickling me makes me irritated. Want to whack someone?
我甚至没有抬头。不，你只是低着头。我一直低着头，直到他走出房间我才抬头。你可以看到当他离开时，我抬头看了他一眼。你知道，那一刻，太尴尬和不舒服了。我没有得到那样的指导，
Does not make me laugh. Well, I thought you did a great job and it was cringy as heck. Poor Jim. I know. All right, we're going to go to a break. Let's take a break. MUSIC Angela, I want to start by asking you a question. OK. You know the scene where Dwight is asking Katie on the date, and it's in front of your character because you're looking at purses? Your face during that moment, what were you thinking?
但我只是觉得太不舒服了。我一直低着头。但“德怀特和安吉拉”还没成为一对。不。但把我们知道你们两个角色之间会发生的事情强加到这一刻太容易了。但人们在问你当时是否知道你们的角色最终会在一起，但你不知道，对吧？
I did not even look up. No, you just kept your eyes down. I kept my eyes down, and then I didn't look up until he walked out of the room. And you can see when he exits, I kind of look up and look at him leave. You know, in that moment, it was so awkward and uncomfortable. I wasn't given direction to do that,
我不知道。我不知道。就在那个会议室里，空间并不大。他那样向她表白，我，作为安吉拉，甚至作为我自己，都感到非常不舒服，以至于我只是试图以某种方式不参与那一刻。就像试图变得隐形。是啊。我在心里想，就变得隐形吧。我想，你知道，安吉拉不知道德怀特会成为她的灵魂伴侣，但我认为她确实把他视为平等的人，
but I just felt so uncomfortable. I just kept looking down. But Duangela is not a thing yet. No. But it is so easy to superimpose what we know is going to happen between your two characters onto this moment. But people were asking if you knew that your characters were going to end up together in that moment yet, but you didn't, right?
她尊重他的职业道德，可能也尊重他在办公室里的身份，尽管他让她很烦，对吧？当然。他们两人之间存在权力斗争。所以看到他那样在凯蒂面前卑微自己并受到羞辱，我只是觉得我甚至不想让他认为我目睹了这一切。
I didn't know. I didn't know. And just in that conference room, it's not a huge space. And him putting himself out there like that to her, I, as Angela, and like even as myself, felt so uncomfortable that I just was trying somehow not to participate in the moment in any way. Like try to just be invisible. Yeah. I was in my mind, I was like, just be invisible. I think that, you know, Angela didn't know that Dwight was going to be her soulmate, but I think she did see him as an equal
我没看见，这没发生，没关系。我想这就是她在想的，这就是为什么我没有抬头。那一刻我真的在试图变得隐形。在那之后，你有一句台词是我最喜欢的你角色的台词，你描述了你最喜欢的颜色。这是艾米的一个粉丝提问。安吉拉，你即兴发挥了你讨论颜色的场景吗？
and she respected his work ethic and probably respected who he was in the office, even though he annoyed her, right? Sure. There was a power struggle between the two of them. So to see him sort of humble himself like that to Katie and get humiliated, I just felt like I didn't even want him to think that I had witnessed it.
是的，我即兴发挥了。我就知道。是的，我即兴发挥了。在这一集中，德怀特看着会议室里的凯蒂和安吉拉在交谈。我们没有任何剧本对话，所以他们说，你们能随便聊聊吗？我甚至不知道这会不会被剪进去。
I didn't see it, it didn't happen, it's okay. That's I think what she was thinking and that's why I didn't look up. I was literally trying to be invisible in the moment. Well after that, you have a line that is one of my favorite lines of your character where you describe your favorite colors. This is a fan question from Emmy. Angela, did you improvise the scene where you discuss your colors colors. This is a fan question from Emmy. Angela, did you improvise the scene where you discuss your colors being different shades of gray?
所以那一幕是即兴的。它以艾米饰演的凯蒂说，嗯，你似乎喜欢触摸东西开始。然后我只是回答，我不一定喜欢触摸东西。我在购物。我喜欢那句台词。然后她说，嗯，你喜欢什么颜色？
Yes, I did. I knew it. Yes, I did. In the episode, Dwight is looking in at the conference room at Katie and Angela sort of talking. And we didn't have any scripted dialogue, so they said, can you just kind of banter? And I didn't even know if it would make it in.
这全是即兴的。我说灰色，深灰色，炭灰色。它被剪进去了。那真的很有趣。然后那句台词最终出现在报纸的一篇文章里。文章在讨论什么总结了这部剧，他们说，嗯，角色安吉拉的台词，“灰色，深灰色，炭灰色”，真的定下了基调。我为那感到非常自豪。那之后确实影响了你很多的服装。你之前一直穿着这些柔和的颜色，但那成为了你以后统一的着装风格。好吧，珍娜，你还有什么？
And so that scene was improvised. And it starts off with Amy as Katie saying, well, you seem to like to touch things. And then I just responded, I don't like to necessarily touch things. I'm shopping. I loved that line. And then she said, well, what color do you like?
好的。瑞安和迈克尔清理他车的场景，那不是即兴的。那是剧本写的。很多人问，所有的，蓝色爆破，闻起来一样，你吃了多少个麦香鱼？所有这些台词都在剧本里。我查过了，因为当我观看时，我很难相信那不是即兴的，所以我回到剧本读了一遍。
And this was all improvised. And I said gray, dark gray, charcoal. And it made it in. and that was really fun. And then that line ended up in an article in the newspaper. It was talking about what sums up the show and they said, well, the character Angela's line, gray, dark gray, charcoal, really sets the tone. And I was so proud of that. It really then informed a lot of your wardrobe after that. You had been kind of wearing these muted colors, but that became your uniform moving forward. Okay, Jenna, what else do you have?
我觉得这只是说明了我们剧的剧本有多好。真的有多好。而且，演员们有多好。我是说，BJ和史蒂夫在那场戏里简直太天才了。明迪也告诉我，关于麦香鱼的引用是对她现实生活中对麦香鱼的恶心热爱，或者只是她对麦当劳的热爱。是啊，喜欢麦当劳。但她确实真的很喜欢麦香鱼。
All right. The scene where Ryan and Michael are cleaning out his car, that was not improvised. Now that was scripted. A lot of people asked, all of it, blue blast, smell alike, how many filet-o-fish do you eat? All of those lines are in the script. I checked because when I was watching it, it was so hard for me to believe that it was not improvised, that I went back to my script and I read it.
我也喜欢这一幕，当迈克尔说，那是一段时间内发生的。好吧。那是一个月内。那是一个月内。临时工瑞安说，还是很多。是啊。我可以一遍又一遍地看那场戏。我觉得那是颗宝石。
And I think that it just points to how good the writing was on our show. Just how good. And also, how good the actors were. I mean, BJ and Steve in that scene Just absolutely brilliant. Mindy also told me that the reference to the filet-o-fishes is a nod to her disgusting Love of filet-o-fish in real life or just her love for McDonald's. Yeah loves McDonald's But that she really does love a filet of fish.
我想如果你还没重温这一集，但你在听播客，请一定要去看那场戏。太棒了。太棒了。蓝色不是一种口味。我有一张笔记卡。说吧。好的。
I loved in this scene too when Michael's like, that was over a period of time. Okay. It was over a month. It was over a month. And Ryan the temp goes, still. Yeah. I could watch that scene over and over again. I think that's a gem.
这是一句很棒的德怀特台词，他说，“鼩鼱会产下非常口渴的幼崽。”哦，是的。那是句名言。那是句名言。我怀孕的时候，我是在《办公室》第五季怀孕的。我收到了一件T恤作为礼物，上面写着“鼩鼱会产下非常口渴的幼崽”。那是一件孕妇装。
I think if you haven't rewatched this episode, but you're listening to the podcast, just please go watch that scene. It's so good. Terrific. Blue is not a flavor. I have a note card. Say it. Okay.
哦，天哪。我穿着它罩住我的大肚子，人们会吓坏的。我还有它，我还有它。哦，你有穿着它的照片吗？我会找找，如果找不到，我就拍一张自己穿着它的照片，我得把它发到Office Ladies Pod上，
This is a great, great Dwight line when he says, Shroots produce very thirsty babies. Oh, yes. That's a famous line. That's a famous line. And when I was pregnant, I was pregnant season five of The Office. And I got a gift of a T-shirt that said, shrewds produce very thirsty babies. And it was a maternity shirt.
因为我还有那件衬衫。你应该发，一定要。这是每个人都写信问的事情。这是我们最受欢迎的问题之一。这一集结尾那个错误的停车场是怎么回事？那是因为这是我们搬迁前的原始布景。前六集，我们都是在一个真实的办公楼里拍摄的，
Oh my God. And I wore that around my big belly and people would freak out. I still have it, I still have it. Oh, do you have a picture of yourself in that? I will look, but if I don't, I'll just take a picture of myself in it and I'll have to post that on Office Ladies Pod
在卡尔弗城，那就是那个停车场。是的。所以当我们第二季及以后搬迁时，我们有两个摄影棚。一个摄影棚是办公室的复制品，也就是我们第一年拍摄的那个室内办公室。另一栋楼是编剧们工作的地方。那只是一栋办公楼，
because I still have that shirt. You should, definitely. Here is something that everybody wrote in about. This was one of our most popular questions. What's up with the wrong parking lot at the end of this episode? That's because this was the original set before we moved. The first six episodes, we all filmed at an actual office
那只是它的停车场。是的。那就是我们拍摄邓德·米夫林停车场的地方。所以这真的很有趣，因为我们在那边有仓库布景，然后我们有停车场。我们还有大厅和汉克坐的电梯。是的，所有这些都是一栋楼，但邓德·米夫林大楼是另一回事。
building in Culver City, and that was the parking lot. Yes. So when we moved in season two and beyond, we had two sound stages. One sound stage was a recreation of the office, that interior office that we shot in the first year. The other building is where the writers worked. And it was just an office building,
所以如果我们必须拍一场戏，看到我们走出来，我们必须在那栋楼开始那场戏，然后把所有的摄像机和我们所有人都搬到另一栋楼，然后拍它的外观版本。是的。这相当复杂。是的，它基本上是，
and that was just the parking lot for it. Yes. And that is where we filmed the Dunder Mifflin parking lot. So it was really interesting because we had our warehouse set over there and then we had the parking lot. And we had the lobby and the elevator where Hank sat. Yes, all of that was one building, but then the Dunder Mifflin building was something else.
我们在一个摄影棚拍室内，在另一个摄影棚拍室外。是的。大部分情况下。但那个停车场不是你在第二季及以后看到的邓德·米夫林停车场。我有一个关于那个停车场的故事。你在最后一个镜头里看到，它以迈克尔和吉姆
So if we had to do a scene where you see us walk out, we would have to start that scene in one building and then move all the cameras and all of us over to the other building and then get the exterior version of it. Yes. It was quite complicated. It was, it was, it basically,
以及凯蒂离开开始。她拿着她的大包。迈克尔意识到吉姆要送她回家，因为他们要去喝一杯。然后镜头揭示了帕姆和罗伊在罗伊的卡车里倒车，帕姆注意到了吉姆和凯蒂。所以大卫和我必须坐在停车场的那辆卡车里，等了很长时间，直到每个人都出来拍那场戏，我们有一个小对讲机
we filmed in one stage indoors and we filmed another stage outdoors. Yes. For the most part. But that parking lot is not the Dunder Mifflin parking lot that you see from season two and beyond. And I have a story about that parking lot. You see in that final shot, it starts with Michael and Jim
在卡车里，他们会说开始。然后大卫会倒车，我们会开出来，摄像机会拍到我看起来很伤心的镜头，然后我们会开车离开，然后他们会说重置，我们会把卡车开回来，然后我们会等很长时间。那天晚上结束时，他们把我们重置回停车场，我们坐在那里，我们坐在卡车里，我们坐在卡车里。然后突然我们看到每个人都开着自己的车离开了。哦，不。他们把我们留在卡车里了。
and Katie leaving. She's got her big bag. Michael realizes that Jim is going to be giving her a ride home because they're going to get drinks. And then it reveals Pam and Roy backing up in Roy's truck and Pam clocks Jim and Katie. So David and I had to sit in that truck in the parking lot and wait a very long time until everyone came out and did that scene and we had a little walkie talkie
他们忘了告诉我们他们已经收工了。哦，珍娜。那天。我们都完成了，我们要离开了。你们完成了。你们在换衣服。你们在进自己的车。我们看到导演离开了，我们看到演员们。
inside the truck and they would say go. And then David would back up and we would pull out and the camera would get that shot of me looking sad and we would drive off and then they would say reset and we would bring the truck back and then we would wait a very long time. At the end of the night they reset us back into the parking lot and we sat there and we sat there in the truck, we sat there in the truck. And then all of a sudden we saw everyone driving away in their own cars. Oh no. They left us in the truck.
大卫和我当时想，什么？这是怎么回事？所以，事情是这样的，我以前说过，大卫·丹曼和我在现实生活中是非常好的朋友。我们在篮球那一集谈过，你和我怎么成了最好的朋友，因为我们必须坐在那个长椅上好几个小时。这真的是大卫和我成为好朋友的那一集。嗯，你们有很多像圣路易斯的联系。我们有共同的朋友，
They forgot to tell us that they had wrapped. Oh Jenna. For the day. And we were all done and we were leaving. You were done. You were changing clothes. You were getting in your cars. We saw the director leave, we saw actors.
我们还有扑克联系。是的。大卫和我与我们的剧组一起玩扑克游戏。我们会举办这些扑克游戏。雷恩也参与其中。克里斯·沃克曼，我们的摄像师之一。埃德，我们的摄像助理。我们都会聚在一起玩扑克。他是其中的一员。所以他是我的扑克伙伴之一。不管怎样，这是我们真正成为朋友的一集，因为我们被留在了那辆卡车里。你们被困在那辆卡车里了。珍娜，你知道吗？我在这里看到了一个主题，你和你被困在狭小空间里的人成了非常亲密的朋友。
David and I were like, what? What is going on? So, and here's the thing, I've talked about this before, David Denman and I were very good friends in real life. We talked about in the basketball episode, how you and I became best friends because we had to sit on that bench for hours and hours. This is really the episode where David and I became such good friends. Well, you had a lot of like St. Louis connections. We did mutual friends
我被困住的人。你就像，你被困在长椅上。我会成为安吉拉最好的朋友。我被困在卡车里。大卫，我们玩扑克吧。和我一起被困在电梯里。然后你就会成为最好的朋友。终生的朋友。
and we had the poker connection. Yes. David and I played in a poker game together with our crew. We would host these poker games. Rain was in on it. Chris Workman, who was one of our camera operators. Ed, our camera assistant. We would all get together and we would play poker. And he was part of that. So he was one of my poker pals. And anyway, this was the episode where we really became friends because we got left in that truck. You got stuck in that truck. Jenna, do you know what? I'm seeing a theme here that you become really close friends with people that you are in a confined space with.
我有最后一张笔记卡。准备好了吗？是的。好的。在大约21分25秒，你看到梅雷迪思，由凯特·弗兰纳里饰演，和梅雷迪思，由亨丽埃特饰演，在同一集中。是的，你看到了，安吉拉。
That I get stuck with. You're like, you're stuck on a bench. I'll be Angela's best friend. I'm stuck in a truck. David, let's play poker. Get stuck in an elevator with me. And then you're gonna be best friends. Friends for life.
我看到了，我差点给你发短信，背景专家。但我心想，不，我要等等看她是否看到了。是的，这是一个巨大的错误。这是一个巨大的错误。所以基本上当迈克尔有这个谈话头镜头时，他们想展示办公室里不同女性的所有片段。他们用了一些试播集里的镜头，
I have my final note card. Ready? Yes. All right. At around 21 minutes, 25 seconds, you see both Meredith, played by Kate Flannery, and Meredith, played by Henriette, in the same episode. Yes, you saw it, Angela.
在凯特·弗兰纳里加入之前，那是亨丽埃特饰演的梅雷迪思。你有这个蒙太奇，从凯特·弗兰纳里到亨丽埃特，再到在附楼里演出的卢安。她是我们很长一段时间的临时演员之一。所以这说得通。我看到了，我为你感到非常兴奋。我感到非常兴奋。
I saw it and I almost texted you, background expert. But I thought, no, I'm gonna wait and see if she sees it. Yes, this is a huge mistake. It's a huge mistake. So basically while Michael has this talking head, they wanna show all these clips of different women in the office. And they used like some footage from the pilot
我看到了，本来差点要发短信给你，背景专家。但我心想，不，我要等等看她有没有发现。没错，这是一个巨大的失误。这真的是个大失误。基本上，当迈克尔在进行访谈时，他们想展示办公室里不同女性的片段。结果他们用了一些试播集的镜头，
before Kate Flannery came on and it was Henriette as Meredith. You have this montage that goes Kate Flannery to Henriette to Luanne who played in the Annex. Who was one of our extras for a very long time. So that makes sense. I saw that and I got so excited for you. I got so excited.
在凯特·弗兰纳里加入之前，当时扮演梅雷迪斯的是亨丽埃特。你看到了一个蒙太奇，从凯特·弗兰纳里切换到亨丽埃特，再到在附楼工作的卢安。她做了我们很长一段时间的临时演员。所以这说得通。我看到那个的时候为你感到特别兴奋。我真的太兴奋了。
Cause you knew I was- I knew you were gonna clock it. You knew I had my note card ready. I have a final little tidbit. I have a Fisher tidbit, the coffee maker. We never find out who won the coffee maker. No. I'm feeling like I need to know.
因为你知道我……我知道你会注意到的。你知道我准备好了笔记卡。我还有一个最后的小花絮。我有一个费舍尔的小花絮，关于那台咖啡机。我们从来没发现是谁赢了那台咖啡机。没有。我觉得我需要知道。
We never find out who won it, and we never see it again. We never see it again. So it doesn't stay in the office. I asked Phil Shea because a fan wrote in. They wanted to know, did any of us get to keep it? People are very interested in the things we're allowed to keep and not keep. I get it. He said no. He said it was borrowed from Starbucks and had to be returned. I believe that. Where is that machine now? I actually believe that and I bet the
我们从来没发现是谁赢了它，也再也没见过它。我们再也没见过它。所以它没有留在办公室里。我问了菲尔·谢伊，因为有粉丝写信来问。他们想知道，我们中有没有人能留着它？人们对我们被允许保留和不被允许保留的东西非常感兴趣。我明白。他说没有。他说那是从星巴克借来的，必须归还。我相信这一点。那台机器现在在哪里？我确实相信这一点，而且我敢打赌
purses were returned because we were on a tight budget and we thought we were getting canceled. Yeah. And we we didn't wanna give NBC any reason to think we were trouble. That's right. So I think I believe that all of that was returned and we got to recoup that money. For sure. Well, Jenna, I think that was some really fun fast facts.
那些钱包也被退回了，因为我们预算紧张，而且我们以为节目要被砍了。是的。我们不想给NBC任何理由认为我们是个麻烦。没错。所以我认为我相信所有这些东西都被退回了，我们得以收回那笔钱。肯定的。好吧，珍娜，我觉得这些快讯真的很有趣。
You did a great job. Wow, thank you. You're welcome. I really appreciate it, Angela. No, no, no. Now I need to hear you sing because if that's what you sound like, I just realized we've never done karaoke
你做得太棒了。哇，谢谢你。不客气。我真的很感激，安吉拉。不，不，不。现在我得听你唱歌，因为如果这就是你的声音，我刚意识到我们从来没一起唱过卡拉OK
or anything together. On the wings of love, only the two of us together flyin' high. Okay, don't sing anymore, we have to pay for it. Um, but now I know you're, now I have got your karaoke voice. And it's whispery. It's whispering.
或者做过类似的事情。在爱的翅膀上，只有我们两个一起高飞。好了，别再唱了，我们得付版权费。嗯，但现在我知道了，现在我听到了你的卡拉OK嗓音。而且是耳语般的。是耳语。
Trying to cover up my flaws. And if you can't really sing, you whisper sing. And that was Hot Girl. And that wraps up season one. Season one where you and I become best friends because you were stuck on a bench with me. And where you also became friends with someone because you were stuck in a car with them.
试图掩盖我的缺点。如果你真的不会唱歌，你就耳语式地唱。这就是《辣妹》。第一季到此结束。第一季里，你和我成为了最好的朋友，因为你被困在长椅上和我在一起。而且你还因为被困在车里而和某人成为了朋友。
See a pattern here. What's gonna happen season two? Who do I get stuck with in season two? Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis.
看出规律了吗？第二季会发生什么？第二季我会和谁被困在一起？感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。